que nous dit que ce soir 15 sénat qui
n'est pas ni dans une logique
constructive ni macron compatibles a un
vrai pouvoir de nuisance pour l'exécutif
pouvoir de nuisance non pouvoir de frein
oui pouvoir de retarder le vote d'un
projet de loi oui pouvoir de blocage
uniquement sur la réforme
constitutionnelle
mais je crois que le sénat qui a
conscience d'avoir une légitimité
discutez-vous leur a plié avec votre
première question qui a conscience
d'avoir une légitimité fragiles ne peut
pas prendre le risque de de jouer une
obstruction systématique à l'assemblée
nationale donc on peut imaginer que le
le sénat va plutôt négocier avec la
sûreté nationale 3 ne peut pas prendre
le risque à part dont il ne peut pas
prendre le risque parce que sa
légitimité n'est pas aussi forte
sa légitimité démocratique il n'est pas
élu au suffrage universel direct non il
est élu au suffrage universel indirect
et l'histoire du sénat qui est dans la
conscience collective des apolitiques
des journalistes des français l'histoire
politique montre que le sénat c'est à
longtemps été un sénat qui retardaient
des réformes ut c'est le sénat par
exemple qui a très longtemps bloqué le
droit de vote pour les femmes c'est le
sénat quelque chose qui va redorer son
image ça c'est pas quelque chose qui va
redonner son image
victor hugo disait il est interdit de
deux mètres un sénat le long de la
république donc le sénat adore notre
histoire une
fragilité institutionnelle on ne discute
pas l'existence de l'assemblée nationale
l'existant du sénat est toujours en
discussion donc il doit lui même faire
attention à l'exercice de son pouvoir
qu'il entame une discussion avec
l'assemblée nationale pour travailler
sur les modalités de la révision
constitutionnelle le champ de la
révision constitutionnelle
l'exclusion de certaines réformes oui de
là à devenir une chambre mélenchonistes
nom ou un vrai contre-pouvoir comme un
vrai client mais le contre-pouvoir il
est davantage si vous voulez dans les
discussions au sein des commissions
parlementaires que dans une assemblée
comme celle du sénat